netflix netflix netflix our favorite
video on demand streaming platform has
made a huge
update well
not actually just a really really small
one but whatever
yeah but it's a pretty cool feature that
shows what people are actually watching
what's up everybody this is zaki here
from geek culture and this is your need
to know about netflix top 10 feature
wow
i forget the situation where
there are
what do you want to watch
i don't know
there's so many things to choose from
well now it gets a whole lot easier
netflix is trying to make it easier for
subscribers to keep up with what people
around the country are watching by
introducing a top 10 role into its
homepage you'll probably notice a brand
spanking new top 10 bench on the top
right corner of the thumbnail image the
top 10 row will be updated every day
with the most popular titles within the
subscriber's country and the position of
the role will also change depending on
how relevant the shows and movies in the
list are to you this way subscribers can
get an even better sense of what's
trending by clicking on the individual
movies and tv show tabs to get the top
10 list of each respective category but
heck it's so hard picking one out as
well let netflix do it for you right tv
series like crash landing on you
narcos
mexico babies
and chefs show because you know food is
good and food is life right
god i'm hungry also movies like deadpool
resident evil vendetta a quiet place
and even frozen because
you know for a hard day's work you gotta
let it go man
there they go
so it's all sorted you know for epic
binge session oh you know
netflix and chill you know
right
i'm so so
i'm so lonely
[Music]
you